sri lanka is running out of food money
and essentials
several people have been killed hundreds
have been injured the prime minister has
resigned and a nationwide curfew imposed
as the country erupted into violence
this island nation of 22 million people
is in a state of emergency these are the
reasons behind the crisis
there is no milk powder no
gas for cooking all the like small
businesses are getting close
the economy in sri lanka was already in
a precarious state before the most
recent unrest
it has significant debt and relies
heavily on gas imports
tourism is vital to help offset these
problems in sri lanka's economy and in
recent years two things torpedoed the
industry
in april 2019
the commercial capital of sri lanka
colombo was targeted in a series of
suicide bombings
islamic state took responsibility for
the attack
more than 250 people died and the
tourism industry was badly damaged
the covert 19 pandemic dealt a further
blow and it also affected other sectors
sri lanka suffered a significant loss of
income and jobs in major economic
sectors like garments and construction
government policies also crippled the
economy
in the wake of the easter bombings in
2019
an election was won by a president who
had made some big promises
his name was gutibaya rajapaksa
and his brother mahinda rajapaksa became
the prime minister
in december 2019 the government
announced it was cutting vat from 15
to just 8
it also abolished 7 other taxes they
were the largest tax cuts in sri lanka's
history but the former finance minister
now admits they led to the country
losing one million taxpayers
not only that the tax cuts led to a
credit rating downgrade the following
year
that meant sri lanka was not only losing
money it was also blocked from borrowing
more
that wasn't the only policy change in
2021 things were beginning to look up
the economy had picked up by eight
percent underpinned in part by a strong
growth in agriculture
but then in may 2021 president rajapaksa
announced a ban on the import of
chemical fertilizers
in a push to promote organic farming
the ban resulted in crop failure and
pushed up food prices
fast forward to today with the war in
ukraine making imports more expensive
the central bank says that the price of
food has increased by almost 50 percent
nationwide protests have been going on
for months
fuel shortages have led to country-wide
power cuts
and lower fruit and vegetable yields
a state of emergency has been declared
and troops deployed
and now almost all of sri lanka's
cabinet have resigned as has the prime
minister
sri lanka's recovery depends on getting
emergency loans and negotiating a
bailout from the international monetary
fund and that can only happen with
political stability